hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play dead
space 3 okay alright we just made our
way into the alien city after jumping
across a giant chasm flying through the
sky like Iron Man and we got these weird
a car great thanks for the tip you
didn't sound too grateful I like this
huh oh hey hey buddy
goodbye buddy hey buddy bye buddy
this is fun
I like this who cares if it's painful
it's amazing that that that actually is
alien technology that we found out in
the last episode so I'm curious as to
how it interacts with human technology
unless they're both there technology
evolved along the same lines I'm getting
a ton of supplies is that it yeah how's
it okay I got it easy puzzles just very
very simple memory stuff going on our
own way man chapter 18 isn't there only
19 chapters I'm getting really close to
the end here I may not have enough room
to carry these no I do not acid bath
hell's to the yeah all right let's drop
this Oh No I keep doing that okay god
help we get a bench soon and Gil on our
way because with that little hoard that
I had to go through again
so I refilled my inventory again act
like it was a chore it was like dog dog
dad and I had to get tons of the items
God sucked but now it was awesome but I
really could use a bench here cuz I get
a lot of stuff that I need to offload
why are there just dead skeletons or
there are those still statues or are
they skeletons because these things are
either huge or they're just full of
themselves ah Who am I kidding I would
have a giant
but this is offline hey wait a minute
this isn't powered we got a problem here
maybe if I just shout it what am I
supposed to do huh no well okay this is
confusing oh I see I'm going the wrong
way should have followed my locator from
the beginning that was my mistake
I am stupid then again you've already
determine that probably would terminate
what the second video I uploaded enough
first video Wow what the hell
where'd you come from
ding-dong a ho airs up bench no power
still I assumed when I power that oh you
[ __ ] right off you triple stage bastard
it's like a boss battle with each little
guy alright anyway we've got tech slog
yes we do let's read about hang up if
you've made it this far
oh okay we're now deep in the heart of
the machine yeah there appeared to be
two primary configuration points one to
the west that you have no doubt already
activated another to the north if they
can be properly compose well to be
honest I don't exactly know what will
happen the only advice I can offer is
this be observant the clues are out
there okay whatever you say just gonna
put my double awesome thing in here do I
have any minus ones yes I do try to get
another damage and yeah I need it knees
reach isn't exactly this one needs rate
of fire like badly so we'll see no I
don't have anything yet I'll get it
later
I'll get it everything later right now I
need dump a lot of inventory please go
away
please go away please go away I'll keep
all the big ones actually I'll just keep
big ones and that little one just a
little leaving you one cuz I know I'm
gonna get more I always get more I'm
just playing so professionally I can't
help but be awesome and get everything
that I need all right so now we can open
this door mmm
to be honest that is kind of a weird
mechanic I mean it's just kind of the
idea that writer probably was in a
border make like what am i by
oh I'm guessing these are just the
equivalent events in ancient alien times
I go I go
just little holes in the wall because
why not
to prowl another one well you hey now
look at you good there by your crack you
can be quick when you want to be doesn't
seem even logical how just too stubby
legs could just but a little bit down
the road but oh well alright what was I
doing
hmm okay so that's up I know I think it
was it no how's it Oh surprised I didn't
think that was actually it okay there
aren't that many potential symbols so
there's only like four or five so the
odds of getting it wrong is pretty love
nice hole in the wall I got a marker
seeing markers all over the place why
are saket wire wire the Necromorphs able
to go so near to the markers unless
they're not real markers fry not real
markers
okay yeah just a fakey fake Iman marker
on the other side I'll get it in a sec I
off piss
ah [ __ ] you
ah where'd you come from
you slow the [ __ ] down
five
good thing I got all this stasis
can't even seem to hit them when they're
coming out of the torso or coming out of
their butt like that
nobody wants tentacles coming out of
their but let me just say that right now
more I know
goodbye
I didn't even get a chance oh here we go
here's my chance
ah don't run weapon Bab ah
Pass
come on shotgun there we go
Jesus I shouldn't have complimented the
holes in the walls
this music is excessively dramatic thank
you very much ha ha ha too bad a buffalo
you are another one oh I gotta get that
in time yes what got me to give me a big
hug
gonna fly through the air to give me a
big hug oh thank you very much but I
don't appreciate your hugs hi there's a
lot of these things I handled it oh so
bro Ashley sorry I'm like I'm like 9/10
pro and 1/10 awesome at 2/10 badass and
5/9 terribly unskilled it's true we're
like oh yeah I'm supposed to get the
scavenging point I got one little Billy
left I'm gonna give me some resources Oh
Jeff wow we are approaching the end here
so there's not much left to go and one
of you said that I missed a really scary
optional mission but I don't know where
it was you just said that door you
skipped and you never considered that I
skipped it because I didn't see it so
I'm like or I skipped which one where
why and how
what did I do wrong is that
wha-oh wrong I'm not wrong that isn't
all it's oh it's a tricky oh sorry sorry
I'm bad they look similar
they're like exactly alike but I guess
subtitles make all the difference in
this game
thank you I'm progress saving oh hello
that makes a weird aliens like
Necromorphs I'm awesome
baddest of ass well what the hell are
those things
what the hell are those thanks Jesus
let's boost on out of here
screw you what are you floating
Necromorphs of evil oh yeah da hájek
look so badass
I bet that hurt too but I'm too awesome
to care God amazing God has made a good
thumbnail hey I got a good test oh uh uh
back up a bit too closer here's your
good framing Isaac you look good
you look damn good okay alright moving
forward die low-production Duff need to
get things up and war hello
go back
tomorrow oh da fair more goopy explode
ease oh hey wait a minute you can't get
behind me like that I saw that ah you
son of a [ __ ]
don't even try it don't even try it
all right it's time to sauce Shaq ha ha
I like the way you flap on the ground
when you die you know you have failed
Wow behind me I hear you
we're all they are nailed it I do not
like those things those things is weird
oh sorry you went off a little
prematurely yeah yeah I saw you thank
you
doesn't take much to kill you I do you
come on out
thank you thank you any left I hear
things moving oh hello come on out no
are you gonna run away smart move
I'm kind of deadly our dad no where you
going you gonna die okay all right you
die and music is done I gotta say the
music is a little too dramatic at some
points like it's like they're trying to
create an atmosphere their dad's death
got counter-intuitive to it
oh no not to goopy I hate to goopy okay
I hear you I hear you I just don't see
you there's one over there but you're
already dead where are you I hear you I
don't see you probably killed a bunch of
those things in the background while I
was jacking around here oh there you are
Oh God
got ya anymore ah I'm out of Billie's I
don't have another Billy I can't
scavenge here
the invasive growth in this area has
made it difficult to make much progress
ah big teams continue to get caught in
the ancient sticky weather no doubt in
my mind that the devices above are
essential the configuration of this
alien machine based on my observations
of the alien shrimp it could be a
soldier amplifier made to move the
signal or power source from properly
alive okay whatever you say bro I think
I know yeah I don't have any Billy's
left I probably got three Billy's
waiting for me back at the bench
wherever the bench is I'm waiting for
the bench for five hours five hours oh
maybe it's up here
maybe there's a bench up here maybe
everything's gonna be okay maybe I panic
too much not not possible I'm perfectly
logical no it was down there time to
panic
okay upgrade circuit oh great a fire
Davidge my favorite all about the DPS
bruh got a maximized GPS you can reload
whatever you need to but you just need
to be able to fire faster and more
hardly hard hearted hard more hard hi
okay so I need to line up these handma
jiggers ha ha
how do I go about doing that oh boy it's
one big puzzle this is a second actuator
for the things well these are just in
reverse order why if they put this one
over there my job would be so much
easier okay here we go ooh super torque
you move your ass ah pick up from Jesus
Christ oh wait this this doesn't this
amplify my oh yeah Gus I need to go give
me that where'd you go okay I have
superpowers while I'm on this platform
so I just need to stay here hey buddy
over there all right so you let's see
you're over there did that solve my
problem did I just need to move that one
if I move that oh wow how were you
sneaking up on me you're just sneaking
up on me like oh he won't notice me no
no way he'll nose me haha oh you all are
so cute laughing all right I need that
thank you you're so adorable but ha ha
ha you can't sneak up on me how about
that check that while you run in you die
all right done
to prom what that I know thank you
what that man you you a loser everywhere
oh jesus okay this is getting a little
dude I see whoa okay you were right
there I did not notice you are they done
oh oh I totally miss boom okay
are we done now I hope so
can I get back to work I think I just
need to turn that see if I turn that oh
I need to hit the other one to make that
more egregious to my configuration so
scares me buddy I wish Josh yeah yeah
all rapid I your rapid fire oh come on
why is this baloney oh no nothing I
thought that was actually gonna be
something okay you ah you're not the
correct one either what are you then
oh well if you had the other one right
there why didn't you just tell me I
would have gladly a minute no wait no
this will work oh this will work this is
gonna work
this is it this is it this is it this is
it
right just got the power line looks like
an open another activation terminal
we're getting closer to fixing this
machine covering yeah Carver wish you
were here with me Brett oh is this
I don't even need stasis for you and you
tentacles aren't as much of the threaded
you used to be I remember when those
used to just one shot you just like if
you even got here business BAM and
you're dead you're gone forever your
whole memory is just erased one blow
finishing something that should have
been done a long time no well stopping
no nothing Dogberry that gadget jackass
ha yeah right back actor jacket Hey yeah
okay where am I going now and I'm going
back down all right getting pretty close
to the end gang getting pretty close to
the end I'm kind of sad to see you go
it's such a girl I like like I know
people criticize it for not being as
scary as the other as the first dead
space and the verse says base was quite
atmospheric and creepy but you gotta
admit the story and the gameplay are
just phenomenal and the story is
completely original well not completely
their inspirations drawn from other
sources but I mean the story and the the
game player what if our important to a
game I mean even if it's not as scary
the fact that it's fun and engaging and
just interesting that we turn the city
into a giant pretzel hey Clara Bert
Serrano is right I should be able to
return to the first activation point to
enter the final setting okay hey I work
on spaceship star alien machines right
uh-huh uh-huh ah Oh their banter I love
it so let's go flying with the alien
goopy fliers whatever the hell those
things are
how about you go FF and you go FF hey my
auto-aim is just like it's automatically
aiming towards it
that's awesome how about you girl I
don't even need to do anything what I
couldn't make this anymore idiot proof
and good cuz imma i'm as i said before
5/9 idiot hey these all should be
already synced up yeah i think the door
is glowing means I can open it I go how
am I going
imma going here wasn't there a bench
somewhere maybe that way I don't know no
I think it was a little bit before this
was that are you an artifact yes
artifact I don't understand why the
people who were here before it didn't
finish this up while they were here and
it seems like that would have been a
priority to do they were pretty close so
I don't know why it's that general that
stopped him right in the beginning
they're stupid [ __ ]
jackass screwing up everything all
higher up military officials I always
screw it up the world dark
oh yeah this is where the bench was this
isn't the way Isaac uh there is a future
for you for all of us you can see them
again eyes not everyone you've lost
along the way it's a future with no
regret I have no regrets ganic one way
or another this will all be over some oh
man Oh Dirk Oh Arthur do you realize
what you're doing
oh look it seems like villains always
have some sort of Britisher UK action of
some sort it's I don't know why but they
seem sinister when they talk a certain
way alright too many again too many I
even got a big one in here so I'm gonna
be good I remember when those used to
actually just like rejuvenate 25 50 and
100 percent I wish they did that again
anyway I got another double so let me
don't need clip in the in the rapid-fire
one the last thing I need is clip so
more ready to fire more tablet well my
gun is turning into an unstoppable
killing machine I don't know what I will
do
okay I just had a thought there was
another thing that I could have put into
my gun but I
I thought against it wait didn't I just
come in from that way oh no wait I came
in that's right there's triple tiered
weird weird construction here damn
humans always screwing everything up
making everything wonky and out of
control
Oh anybody here
what about you Tom I hear some goopy out
there
oh no that's goopy in here never mind I
hear Shawn Mount God JJ that's what I
thought I heard retreat go thank you
wait hold on no you and then
pass out stop dubbing
please stop methane you are almost dead
I freaking blew your head off and you
would not stop moving another 1/2 of
other ones too
another ones Oh Frick I'm out of stasis
ah there we go
sploded into a shower of items unloved
wide um Annie why do I keep missing
hey ii might work better
oops fast there we go
it's not totally effective as a grenade
launcher but it does the job
o best he looks angry
our clothes another one Jesus come on
man some hurting it over there that I
don't know about
what the hell is going on over there
buddy
oh I see you're releasing little babies
and they were exploding all over each
other well that was your fault man
they sound like balloons rubbing against
each other that's so weird
stop it you're so weird
why don't you pop each other what is
weird
uh-oh
I was wrong in a lot of ways I chewed up
a lot of my ammo I'll tell you that I
mean I didn't have anything to throw at
him well maybe I could have tea Kade one
of the bigger bricks I didn't think
about that damn up Wow don't Dupin I
could've died Danka I kind of died so I
get screwed up let's go fly again I wish
there was more game mechanics involved
with us flying because it's gonna be
really cool
like if I had to fly back up into space
cuz it dead space - you flew down from
space I love that sequence that was one
of my favorite sequences but I wish you
could fly back up now be cool
what is that I see something Wiggly
Wagle in the distance there oh that's
right I just remembered I left a couple
monsters here oh I hope they're not just
waiting oh there there oh you all uh
I've gotta leave you all to your own
devices oh I could see I can just go up
the stairs ignore actually I want this
bench here so I might take here we go
but don't shoot me you got a bigger
problem to deal with
good there you go I'll help you
Wow how do you come from no thank you
maybe I should have just gone up the
stairs
no you don't go
ah okay you're dead you're going to be
dead you can't handle the shotgun nobody
can handle the shotgun alright so that
was a long way to go for the bench but I
appreciate your candor candor is that
the appropriate word to use in this
scenario I have no idea
ah Pass I'm running close on time and I
don't want to interrupt anything if I
get into it so I may just actually take
a little bit of a breather here as I get
some more ammo that's what I needed
haven't I needed at um a tungsten torque
bar in a while I'm kind of disappointed
because I made those assuming there
would be plenty of them cuz even at the
end of the game there were power nerd
rooms and uh let me see something I just
I was looking at this before because I
remember that I had fire one two
attachment to no no okay attachment to I
didn't know I haven't a second it okay
acid bath that's what it was
acid damage over time that would be
freaking awesome and there was this MK 5
ammo box automatically reloads I would
love to see that because we load is one
of the most reloading is one of the most
Oh Oh God lota I just don't know what
these combos do I haven't had a chance
to actually look at him but it's MK 5 it
reminds me of Mass Effect of all the x
and v and numbered weapons hmm okay all
right I'll try it just to give it a try
but where was the other attachment I
guess I don't get an attachment
nevermind done screw that whatever
just me and my squeezy marker gun and
marker everything in marker marker
everything basically I'm crazy crazy
cuckoo okay I'm gonna end it here
because I do not want to interrupt
anything
because I got a feeling that as soon as
I open the door up there or do whatever
I need to do up there I will be
progressing myself into a story and an
ending that I don't want to interrupt so
it looks like the next episode is going
to be the last
episode maybe probably probably going to
be so I hope you all are enjoying this
band I hope I hate to see you this go
but I want it all to be in one choke so
it may be an extra-long episode next
time so thank you everybody so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos if I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video bye
ah
your turn
buzz
Oh
out